ورشه التغيير التي عاصفه بتويتر فتحت باب
الموقع عالم اسرائيل عمال المقالون او
مستقلونا من جهه ومن الجهه الاخرى يهرب
المعلنون العشرات من كبار المعلمين على
تويتر اوقفوا اعلاناتهم اكثر من 33 جهه
تسويقا كبرى لم تعلن على تويتر في
الاسبوعين الماضيين وفق صحيفه واشنطن
بوستا لتشهد صفحات العصفور الازرق غياب
افضل 14 معلنا على المنصه من ضمنهم شركات
جيب وجننال موتورز التاني اوقفت الاعلانات
المدفوعه على تويتر بشكل مؤقتا وفي خطوه
مماثله اصدرت مجموعه امكم للدعايه
والتسويق في الثانيه عشر من نوفمبر توصيه
لعملائها بوقف انفاقهم مؤقتا على اعلانات
تويتر علما بان امكم تخدم اكثر من خمسه
الاف عميلا في 70 دوله بينهم ماكدونالدز
وابل ولم يعرف ان تبع اي من عملائها
التوصيات هذه الخطوات والصفات بالمؤشر على
تقلب المعلمين وشكوك الوكالات والعلامات
التجاريه حول مستقبل الموقع بعد الاستحواذ
الفوضووي للملياردير الون ماسك عليه ورغم
مساعي ماسك الحثيثه لخفض التكاليف وايجاد
اشكال بديله للارادات يعتمد تويتر بشده
على الاعلانات التي شكلت 90% من ايراداته
العام الماضي في مصر صاحب منصه الجديد
يرجع الانخفاض الكبيره بالايرادات الى
ضغوط مجموعات حقوقيه على المعلمين لمقاطعه
الخدمه لحين توضيح كيفيه تحكم تويتر
بالمعلومات المضلله وخطاب الكراهيه